hello everyone and welcome back to the
2019 feet a gram three it's the finals
young treat of Duda versus Alexander
Grisha sorry about not showing this game
earlier but we were kind of busy with
the tall game and everything and I
forgot to mention in the previous video
the one where you could enter the
giveaway the giveaway will be on
Saturday during the rendering well not
during the tournament but after the
tournament we're gonna be playing some
games so I forgot to mention in the
previous video a video if you want to
enter the giveaway in the previous video
the one where tall faces Miller you'd
have to comment something about tall and
write hashtag tile so in the the first
thing you will see in the description
below is a link to that video if you
want to enter the giveaway do go to that
video and write something well hopefully
nice about tile and use hashtag top but
any anything you can write anything and
use hashtag tile that will also work but
it would be nicer if you write something
nice about that and also I forgot to
mention in the previous video every time
I reach a milestone at this time there
are 500,000 subscribers I always invite
my viewers to check out my video when I
reached 1000 subscribers so if any of
you are interested in doing YouTube or
you know or maybe maybe you don't think
that you have what it takes that to be
on YouTube check out the video I made
when I reached 1000 subscribers and you
will immediately change your mind
because it's quite different from the
videos I make now
so the second link in the description
below will be that video do check it out
and hope it inspires you as it is it is
quite bad so there you have it now
getting back to this game this is still
this is Game two of their classical
encounter because first they're playing
to class for games then they're going
into Rapids and you know drill the first
game of the classical time control ended
in a draw I didn't feel the need to show
it as it was it was a pretty pretty
draws game and not a lot of action going
on so I know you know you guys don't
enjoy that but this game it's a bit
different it's the second game of the
classical time format and this time Duda
has white and the Greek has the black
pieces so without further ado let's
check out the game Duda opens the width
before sorry about that we have a night
to have
6x3 shock we have c4 e6 and of course we
have the Queen's Gambit a client ID 3 D
5 Knight to c3 Bishop to e7 and Bishop
to f4 now we have castles and now comes
a three
now that the bishop is out of the cage
you you can just close across the
structure Knight B to d7 preparing c5
and rook the C 1 we have c5 by black a
lot of tension going on in the center D
captures on c5 Knight captures we have
seek after Snipes captors and even one
more trade Knight captures and it
captures on d5 and this position has
been reached several times and always in
this position a3 was played and a3 is
played in this game by Duda makes sense
if Queen to a5 chair comes you want to
be able to block it with before even win
a PC if possible and here there are
moves that black played Bishop to e6 is
a non move Bishop to g4 is a non move so
basically we want to develop your light
square Bishop and prepare at the
development of the rockin c8 but here
Grisha plays it Bishop to d7 it's a new
move in the position and it is already
as a move 11 that we have a completely
new game on our hands so what's a Bishop
to d7 it's a it's a really weird move I
mean this is a much more active square
this is a much more active square and on
the other hand Bishop to d7 says are you
interested in this nice juicy pawn so
here Duda really spent a lot of times
time trying to calculate what what is
this sorcery agree Shakur is doing
already on move 11 and can he actually
grab the d5 pawn because it's a grease
shock you know anything can happen so
here after I think Duda took some 15
maybe even more than 15 minutes at
decide on this move and he decided to
capture the d5 pawn and okay what what
does black play here and it's
interesting I can't figure out if Grisha
had this Bishop to d7 move prepared at
home or was it an inspiration over the
board because here if you put this
position to an engine it will give you a
lot of interesting ideas
Queen to a5 check being only one of them
and it is the one that we're going to
explore so Queen to a5 check we said
that it doesn't work because of b4 but
here since the Queen is no longer
guarding the rook and c1 here before
doesn't really work because now you can
just cap
from a three and if the night is
captured you're just gonna capture the
rook here with check so here what would
have to go for route captures but you're
not gonna give up the two pieces for a
rope you're gonna go Queen before check
and now it's just winning for black you
have to block or something just Bishop
captures and black is completely winning
here so this is one of the options you
have after Queen to a5 check another
option is just to block with the rook
rook c3 but then you can play Bishop to
e6 now grabbing a lot of development for
that sacrificed pawn and here before
attacking the Queen Queen to a4 and here
after white moves the Queen let's say
Queen to h5 now you can play rook the c8
and here are really just a lot of mess
happens on the board because you cannot
capture the night that's the whole point
if you capture the knight then Queen a5
and then now your rook is under attack
you cannot defend it and it's too easy
to add more attackers to the rook
address and c5 will add another attacker
bishops or hey sorry Bishop to f6 will
add another attacker and the black will
just win this game easily so after Queen
to a5 check before not a good move rook
c3 not a good move but there is Queen to
d2 and here queen capture Sundy to check
followed by Knight character Sundy to
and the rook ate the c8 with the thread
of Knight the d3 check which would pick
up the rook and c1 so here you would
have to defend this let's say Ruby d1
but now Bishop the a4 kicks the rogue
back
Ruby 1 and now look after the 8 and for
the price of 1 point you've mobilized
all of your pieces so this is one way to
go about it but that's why that's why
I'm saying that after Queen captures on
d5 it's hard to say if a grecian
prepared better up to d7 over the board
or was an inspiration over the world or
was it some crazy home preparation
because Queen to a5 check was not played
rook
8 to c8 was a Greek ships move and okay
we have E 4 by Judah and now comes Queen
to b6
getting the Queen into the game also
Queen captures and b2 might be an idea
with before attacking the knight and
here comes rook F to D 8 so Grisha
offers the knight on c5
but not really as you'll see in the game
so Duda accepts the night will be
captures and c5 and
Bishop captures nc5 so threatening to
capture an f2 with check and also do
this King is still in the center of the
board so it's quite an unpleasant
position do defines the very strong
Bishop to e2 and this was probably the
toughest move to find because well you
have to you have to calculate it after
Bishop captures and King f1 the white is
okay that okay you will have some
problems developing the road but once
you play g3 and maybe get the king over
to G to bring the rook into the game it
you will be fine and also c1 is defended
by the bishop so that's not a problem
the light square bishop doesn't have
doesn't have any any excellent
discoveries so that's not a problem
either and all in all white would what
would be okay here
so this is what do the found when he
found the ship to e2 an incredibly
strong move so there should be five as
Duda also prepared castling doesn't fall
out he says ok you castle I went back my
piece that is the bishop on e2 so here
do the place another excellent move the
only good move in the position rook
captures on c5 you can't hold on to that
much material you have to give something
back
we have rope captures on c5 and now
Queen to b3 getting the Queen back also
not allowing the bishop characters here
Queen the c6 not unpinning again you
cannot Castle because just the ship
character Sonny do and here we have
Bishop to e3
attacking the rook here and grecian goes
for Bishop captures an e2 he says okay
you can capture with the King and then
I'm just gonna go Queen to a6 check and
your king is staying in the center of
the board
but Duda played Bishop captures on c5
instead he says I'm gonna trade down as
much as possible before I decide whether
my King stays in the center of the board
and here is where there was a lot of
Twitter controversy were well played
Bishop captures on f3 everyone said that
ok Queen captures on e4 is a must play
move because ok everyone sees that after
Queen captures on e4 there are obviously
a lot of very nasty discoveries here and
if you play something like a bit of the
e3 it would be very unpleasant for white
because after Bishop the before with an
attack on the Queen once the Queen moves
the King remains in the central
the board due to the lights worship and
okay it doesn't matter that your
sacrifice material this rook is not not
coming into the game anytime soon
the problem is after Queen captures any
for you have Knights to d2 and this is a
very nice defensive resource because now
after Queen captures Angie - you have
King captures on E - this is the point
and here it's gonna it's a very doubled
edgy game Queen captures on h1 with
Czech Bishop captures on a7 Queen
captures on h2 Queen captures on b7 and
you get this position for example after
Queen to d6
threatening just to capture the night
here where White has a bishop and the
night for a rook but with the White King
being so wide open it's well only black
can be better here even though white
should be better but with with so many
options of checking the White King this
is for a human this is this is
unplayable so this is a something that
you could have gone for with Queen
captures on e4 but the problem is this
is the second game of the classics if
Grisha loses this he's well he just lost
the feed at Grand Prix and he's fighting
for first place which would really mean
a lot to him regarding the
qualifications to the candidates
tournament so here grey shirt went for
Bishop captures an f3 just winning
winning bag of the piece and okay Queen
captures on f3 Queen captures on c5 now
the material is equal he wins back his
pawn and Duda takes this opportunity
because he's not gonna get another one
to castle finally we have castles and
also Grichuk has a very very nice chance
this year basically the plan is B 5a v
b4 and create a passed pawn on the Queen
side maybe put a room behind it and push
it to victory so that's what guk is
betting on we have b5 he starts with
this plan and now h4 Duda makes an
escape route for his king so he can
start activating pieces with h6 agree
sugar does the same and now rook the b1
and here gireesham doesn't go for a 5 he
doesn't for some reason he abandons the
plan or maybe it wasn't a plan at all to
just create it right away he instead
plays a 6 he says okay as long as your
Lucas here I'm gonna keep my pawn on a6
if you decide to play something else
then maybe a 5 B 4 is an idea so yes
it's one of those
the threat is stronger than the
execution ideas but okay look the b3 by
Duda now getting a defender to the
entire third rank so the Queen doesn't
have to keep an eye on the a3 point you
can now activate the Queen and the Queen
e5 a nice centralizing move with the
Queen covering the h2 square so if the
Queen moves from the defense of the d1
square you can also just deliver mate
so g3 do that takes care of that and the
now rook the d4 piling up on the on the
e4 pawn we have looked a three do the
defends it and now finally a5 preparing
before now Grichuk is ready to create a
passed pawn queen to g4 with ideas of
Queen to CH check and then Reema
nuvaring the Queen over to the Queen
side maybe even maybe even something
like King G 2 2 H 3 or f4 could be an
idea in the future but very unlikely you
don't want to open up your King more
than necessary before finally by Griff
shook a captures a captures the passed
pawn is created and now Queen to c8
check this is what dude ahead in mind
King to h7 and now Queen to b7 adding a
defender again to d4 pawn and also
putting a room behind the pass pawn is
great putting a queen behind the
passport is it's even better
well regardless if it's your own phone
or your opponent's pawn also the f7
point is under attack so first f6
removing that threat and now King g2
just improving the safety of the King
rook the c4 and now comes Queen to d5
now do that offers a trade of Queens and
agrees we accept with characters
captures and now rook the d4 again
putting the rocker behind the passed
pawn and we have looked the b3 now if
you capture the pawn on d5 you lose the
pawn on b4 and then we would have just a
three-on-three on the Kings side of
course a completely drawn endgame King
to g6 Grichuk starts bringing the King
into the game we have King to f3
we have h5 and now comes King to e3
attacking the rook and here you don't
really have a better option you could go
rook to g4 and try to make the game last
longer but after f3 you will have to
trade some of the point so here Grisha
went look after sandy 5 rook captures
and before and it was in this position
unmoved 38 that the
agreed to a draw so very exciting stuff
and there were a lot of a lot of moves
where issue could have maybe brought
more poison to the game with that Quinte
5 check maybe or maybe with that Queen
captures on e4 but it's it's hard to say
how much of this grace shock had
prepared at home and how much was
inspiration over the board so maybe he
already had it all figured out and we
will just never know if any of you maybe
checked the interview or if there was an
interview about this game and you have
some more knowledge about this do share
in the comments and I will of course
spin it so everyone else can see but
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it like I said don't forget to
enter the giveaway at the first link in
the description below
use hashtag stop on your comment and
also the second link in the description
below my video when this channel reached
1000 subscribers if you want to see how
the channel looked back then it was
really bad so you know maybe it will
inspire some of you to take up YouTube
who knows how but yeah I would like to
thank James Dunn henry Campbell peter
Skowronski I go cool G and Taylor Morgan
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot - really appreciate it as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the Fida
Grand Prix and checking up in your
wonderful suggestions so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day